I love cooking for mates but I never
made the mistake of doing complicated
formal food who wants to be stressed out
on the time off however I do have a
reputation to keep up so the food has
got to be good whether it's breakfast
brunch lunch or dinner here's my
ultimate food for friends
having people over for a bit of a late
breakfast or brunch at the weekend is a
brilliant way to catch up with friends
and this dish is always a winner
gorgeous griddle polenta with roasted
tomatoes and a creamy ghost curd I can't
wait to dive in next a lunch to knock
the socks off your mates Sensational
salt bait sea bream with easy braised
leeks and my middle daughter Holly gets
her hands dirty in the kitchen as we
cook a super simple dinner
guaranteed to be a hit with all your
loved ones stunning roast chicken
stuffed with aromatic chickpeas
a beautiful big green salad and an
amazing chocolate and hazelnut meringue
Tower
really good nice to see Holly get her
hands dirty right I think we all agree
oh this is my ultimate food for friends
breakfast lunch and dinner
first I said I suffocated late breakfast
or brunch dish to impress your mates
easy griddle polenta with delicious
roasted tomatoes and creamy goats curd
now polenta to the Italians is what
mashed potato is to Britain's a staple
incredibly delicious and really
straightforward to do now season the
water
it's a little touch of olive oil stops
it from becoming too sticky
I love polenta it's a cornmeal made from
ground dried maize
the more coarse the longer it takes to
cook but you can also buy instant
polenta which is ready in under 10
minutes and always use this at home
and then
whisk that out
as it Cooks out
it naturally thickens
you can see the grains becoming almost
into one nice fine pureed
polenta to take the polenta to another
level flavor wise season with salt and
pepper a good knob of butter and
Parmesan the quite generous with the
parmesan because blender can be quite
dull I like it quite rich and creamy
delicious
now mix that in
no a nice smooth shiny glossy plant you
can eat polenta two ways like this it's
a glorious fluffy Mash or set then
griddled which is what I'm doing
start by oiling a baking tray pour in
your polenta
now get that in the fridge and then it's
set
next I'm roasting fine tomatoes to
really intensify the flavor
olive oil on the bottom of the tray and
drizzle extra virgin olive oil on top
nip your tomatoes with your scissors if
you didn't burst them before they went
in the oven they'd explode so
and pepper garlic
just squeeze the juice out the garlic
says the tomatoes blister and roast it's
going to take on all this lovely garlic
to give the tomatoes a wonderful sweet
and sour flavor a pinch of sugar and
balsamic vinegar
this is a wonderful age balsamic vinegar
and then some time don't pick the time
just trim it like you're having a little
haircut nice
the tomatoes only take 10 minutes to
roast
now the plant is set it's ready to
griddle
should just fall out beautiful blend is
a nice garnish for grilled Meats it's
great when you're planning a big dinner
party
the Plenty can be done one or two days
before a nice season
top and bottom
a nice sort of coating of olive oil and
then onto your grill
now
this looks very impressive but it's so
easy to do
get that Grill really nice and hot make
sure you've got a fish slice and go
underneath
to turn all that nice sort of marking
and Char on the blender gives that
really nice flavor
now tomatoes
no
you've got these beautiful Vine tomatoes
that have been roasted and all that
wonderful flavor
now get your little tomatoes and just
sit them on top
drizzle over any remaining roasting
juices
the perfect addition is a goat's curd
goat's curd gives it that nice sort of
salty creamy
taste goat's cheese cream cheese or
creme fraiche will work just as well
drizzle
a little touch
of that age basement vinegar and then a
little basil
I can't wait to dive in
this dish is fantastically entertaining
in the morning set your plan to the
night before and you can have this
casual brunch on the table within
minutes fuss-free cooking that looks
like a labor of love
coming up I've got some great lunch and
dinner recipes when you're cooking for a
crowd
[Music]
but first here's a closer look at some
of the key ingredients you'll need to
impress your friends
[Music]
keep your guests sweet here's some of
the most common sugars and what they're
best for
almost sticky muscovado sugar rich and
trickly in flavor it's great in biscuits
fruit cakes and pickles
powdery icing sugar dissolves without
heat making it perfect for butter creams
and icing
palm sugar made from the palm tree sap
is generally sold as a paste and brings
caramely flavors to Sweet and Savory
dishes
the secret to the meringue I'm serving
my mates for dinner is caster sugar part
way between granulated and icing sugar
in size it dissolves well it's the
ultimate sugar for baking
for the main course I'm using corn-fed
chicken you can buy them everywhere
they're great value they have a lovely
color and a rich flavor and with an
incredible stuffing roast chickens
guaranteed to be a crown pleaser
sea bream and I think the Kilt head
variety with its disco Diva gold flash
is the most flavoursome
to check it's fresh its eyes should be
bright gills red and scales shiny
bream's great poached grilled or pan
fried but I'm going to bake it in a salt
crust for my ultimate lunch for friends
when I'm cooking lunch for a crowd of my
friends my policy is to keep it simple
and think big so instead of making lots
of little things I usually cook a whole
fish or a large joint of delicious meat
that way there's always plenty to go
around now you can have this prepared
and in the oven before any of your
guests arrive it looks super impressive
especially when you bring it to the
table this is my ultimate lunch for
friends
salt crusted Sebring served with braised
leeks and hazelnuts
first job is that salt crust this dish
looks intimidating but it is actually
very straightforward and very easy make
sure the guts are out and the fish is
clean the most important thing is always
leaving the skin and the scales on that
skin protects the actual flesh from
becoming salted give the fish a really
nice seasoning
inside even though we're putting a salt
crust on the outside it's still very
important to season the middle fennel
seeds
goes brilliantly well with Fish And then
slice the lemon nice large thick slices
the zest
and the lemon bakes inside the fish
fall over the fish and just squeeze the
juice now for the salt
about 150 mil to 200 mL of water
what you're trying to do now is bring
the salt together and you want to sort
of end up with a bowl of salt that looks
almost like snow
you'll need about two kilos of salt for
this and it doesn't need to be the fancy
stuff even though you're using a lot of
it it won't make the fish salty instead
the crust forms a kill that retains
moisture well basically
a nice bed of salt underneath
flatten it down
lay the fish on top of the salt get your
salt
and just start packing you can salt
crust almost any fish from sea bass to
Salmon or flatfish like soul but it's
not great with oily fish
now it looks like a ridiculous amount of
salt but it's really important to cover
all the fish
because you want that nice shell and the
minute salt hits the oven it sort of
tightens up and forms this
large crust that goes in at 180 degrees
for 25 to 30 minutes
whilst the fish Cooks is onto my
beautiful braised leaks splash of olive
oil leak is a very sort of firm robust
vegetable so it can take a really nice
Sear
the most exciting thing about these
leeks I either go beautifully for
deceivering but braised leeks colored
properly with a lot of flavor on there
tastes absolutely delicious
take a couple of cloves of garlic and
just crush them in with the leeks some
fresh thyme
get some butter in there
braising them in butter and white wine
gives them the most amazing flavor
braising as a chefy term for searing at
a high temperature then cooking with a
bit of liquid
bring that up to the boil
and then
the rest of your butter
now
as the white wine reduces down the
flavor the leeks intensifying they glaze
turn it down
just leave that little Gap there if we
totally
covered it then you're gonna get all
that condensation underneath the lid and
it'll just make the legs watery the
leaks will take about 12 minutes to cook
so now for the garnish roasted hazelnuts
they'll be roasting the oven very
brittle very firm so get them inside
pesto mortar bit of seasoning and just
crush your nuts
don't over pound them I just want this
nice sort of rustic chopped toasted
hazelnuts now get your knife you want
that going through with ease and turn
off the gas
all right absolutely adore them
like stunning little parcels
soft and slightly creamy
now baste the leeks with the remaining
butter
spread your fat leaf parsley over
generously
and then just sprinkle
The Toasted hazelnuts
the combination of that earthiness from
the leeks the roasted flavor from the
hazelnuts that is a stunning way of
eating leeks
and now for the fish
I'm not now just gently tap
the top
and it starts falling away you can just
see that beautiful
shine carefully lift off
your salt now peel that skin look how
juicy and succulent that Sebring is
stays incredibly moist
the other great thing about cooking
whole fish like this it makes it so easy
to fill it
your spoon
run that down
through the top
the fish will just slide off
there now
just
push back that lovely fillet and look
at that is cooked beautifully and that's
what keeps them coming back for more
and more and more when you have friends
over you want to keep lunch relaxed lay
back but impressive and a salt crust
brain with beautiful braised leeks is
just that
one of the things I've learned about
running successful restaurants over the
past 20 odd years is it's not just the
food that keeps people coming back you
need to create a great atmosphere too
and it's the same at home
My ultimate dinner for friends is
utterly delicious but it keeps things
simple and easy in the kitchen
[Music]
helping me in the kitchen proving this
dinner's Child's Play to make is middle
daughter Holly first shop get the
chicken stuffed and roasting
now we all know
you love chicken I do
but we're going to do it the way that
Daddy used to eat it in Paris okay now
I'm gonna hold that up okay season
inside please why is it yellow because
it's a comfort chicken obviously eats
corn and if you eat lots of corn
now what are those
chickpeas chickpeas yeah have a little
taste
nice yeah we're gonna make them taste
even better salt pepper in there as well
please now
chilies
can you hear that noise was that made
the seeds have come out that's right
take off the tops
we're gonna add the chilies to the
chickpeas in
and then
zest the lemon in there please you love
your zest I love my zest
the absolutely right a little glug of
olive oil
come on house don't worry about your
nails now come on baby you can do it
now time you pick off all those
wonderful little buds
see
so as we stuff the chicken with the
fresh thyme
the chickpeas become sort of fat and
juicy from all that wonderful flavor
chickpea stuffing done next we're going
to make the herb butter to flavor the
skin now what's that Target
hmm slightly vinegary yeah yeah a little
bit and a CD yeah so imagine that flavor
going into the chicken that's gonna be
delicious now nice soft butter in with a
tarragon
is that lovely yeah now I want you
gently to put your fingers through there
and just so we can get that butter under
there but I need those small beautiful
little hands
what's wrong it's yucky come on holes
nice well done I want you
get a nice handful of butter
oh
lift your hand up and push under good
now see that there yeah you push it all
the way down there and you let that
slide and that's how you get all that
wonderful
yeah butter running down and the breasts
stay nice and moist and like you
yeah all those chickpeas in there nice
your hands have never been so dirty have
they no here we go
good and push down
come on okay now place my lemon in there
right take your garlic should I wash my
hands no not yet we're gonna eat the
garlic
onto the tray now
onto the garlic
salt
pepper make your skin nice and crispy
and then I'm just going to drizzle some
olive oil that'll stop the butter from
burning and look at that
please open the door thank you everybody
and she goes
beautiful good job
thank you really good it's nice to see
Holly get our hands dirty right I think
we all agree huh
for dessert it's an incredible but easy
hazelnut meringue Tower guaranteed to
wow your mates
start with the basic meringue separate
four egg whites
[Music]
and whisk
gradually add caster sugar
[Music]
until the mix forms stiff glossy Peaks
gently folding ground and chopped
hazelnuts
a trick we use in the restaurants is to
use the mix to stick baking sheets down
which makes them easy to spread and
stops the sheets blowing around
top your meringues with more finely
chopped hazelnuts
and bake for 25 minutes
and the trick to stop them cracking is
to turn the oven off and let them cool
inside
for the filling melt dark chocolate in a
bowl over simmering water
and slightly cool
whip the cream until it forms soft peaks
and gently fold in three quarters of the
melted chocolate until combined
build your towel with alternate layers
of chocolate cream and meringue
[Music]
finally drizzle over the remaining
melted chocolate to decorate
a simple yet luxurious dessert your
friends will love but be warned they'll
all want second helpings
[Music]
the chickens in the oven and the
desserts sorted now for a big easy green
salad
so
let's start off with one nice tablespoon
Dijon a nice little squeeze of honey
honey yes and it will Splash
oh
aged
and this is your favorite this one isn't
it I just like the it has a nice
sweetness but then it has a better Nest
to it too nice
at least a virgin olive oil why do we
have to use a whisk not just a spoon the
purpose of using a whisk is so it can
emulsify that more importantly you're
bringing all the ingredients together
taste
it's so yummy that is delicious
isn't it
tip to loosen any vinaigrette and give
it a lighter taste is add a spot of
water now the juice
of a Lemon Squeeze lemon in
nice now use some butter lettuce start
placing the salad around the outside
this one is a lullo Rosso
okay
so we'll put that one on the inside
we're sort of making a nice flower and
you put your heart in there
that's exactly what I'm trying to do a
nice beautiful flower
now
from there
crisscross your avocado what does
criss-crossing do instead of just
exciting down I'll show you now you put
your
spoon in there and look that's so cool
all these nice little bits I want you to
sprinkle those little bits in here
I'm telling you that first dinner you
cook for your boyfriend is going to be
extraordinary yeah that romantic dinner
the roast chicken the beautiful salad
okay yeah so where your father taught
you
and how nice will that be all three of
us sat down eating at the same time very
nice
[Music]
all of you
all of you and I'd grab the chicken okay
now
look at this beauty
yeah amazing doesn't it right so a
little bit
what drizzle it
nice what I'm gonna do now squeeze
all that garlic
and see how soft and beautiful it is
smells amazing the lemon that we stuffed
inside the chicken roasted
what we do now is just squeeze all that
through
look at that nice
garlic puree into all my
chickpeas
in there from there
[Music]
now you crush them
because they're still nice hot
they absorb all that wonderful garlic
and lemon puree they're rich
delicious creamy vinaigrette chilies
I can guarantee you young lady but they
are the best
the finest the most delicious chickpeas
you've ever tasted
[Music]
go on then see
right
and
now it will drizzle
thanks a virgin olive oil over them
beautifully done
[Music]
on chickpeas
and that is a roast chicken Fit For A
King dying this looks really yummy
how many pasta salad out please an old
carve the chicken whole roast chicken
stuffed with chickpeas served with a big
green salad it's always a winner with
your buddies workmates or family recipes
are really really rich they're great
stuffing is amazing I love chickpeas
because I like cheese from chicks
your first chicken recipe for you and
your boyfriend there are loads more
great home cooking recipes on my app
cook with me you can find it in the App
Store good luck
[Music]
full of sumptuous homely dishes today's
all about comfort food I think every
home cook needs recipes that don't just
taste delicious but to satisfy the soul
too the type of food that wraps its arms
around you and gives you big hugs so
when you want to give your family and
friends a big serving of Love here's my
ultimate comfort food dish is guaranteed
to make you feel cozy even on the
coldest of days
first up a breakfast that will bring you
a warm glow in the morning my spiced
baked porridge perfect for a big Comfort
family breakfast for lunch I'm pulling
out all the stops with a fantastic Twist
on one of Britain's favorite comfort
dishes ginger beer battered fish with
chili minted mushy peas It's Gonna Do It
do it properly for dinner my youngest
daughter Tilly is in the kitchen and we
share the secret ingredient in every
comfort food dish happy memories did you
like to help Nan make your hot pot when
she made them for you always sausage hot
pot with beetroot and potato gratins on
the menu for dessert spiced apple compot
silly we're on for a treat this is my
ultimate comfort food breakfast lunch
and dinner
first up it's breakfast my spiced baked
porridge
absolutely love it why
I grew up with it there's something very
Scottish about porridge it's that kind
of sort of great start to the day my
father used to say porridge needs salt
and salt only it separates the men from
the boys didn't really like it it was
insisted salt puts hairs on it I used to
sneak a couple of sugar lumps from cafes
and put them in my porridge without him
watching these days my porridge has much
more flavor than just salt it's packed
with fruit nuts and spices add vanilla
seeds to porridge oats or oatmeal really
important just to rub the vanilla
through
the oatmeal makes it nice and fragrant
now a little teaspoon
of cinnamon makes it spicier and then
nutmeg
[Music]
already
that
smells incredible I quite like making
this up week at a time and Jack
absolutely loves it now whole almonds
now if you don't like that kind of
crunch running through the porridge you
can chop these up or blend them to a
powder but I quite like the sort of
texture hazelnuts incredibly good
a really nice crunch keep your vanilla
pot in there as well that just gives it
even more lift and of course once it's
baked just pull it out instead of sugar
I'm adding sweetness with fruit fresh
pears and raisins
cranberries are great as well chopped
apricots as well dried apricots in there
dried mango I love dried fruit next pour
in a pint of milk and mix
it can be done the night before left in
the fridge and then a couple of minutes
before you go to bake it add your cream
into your dish
it looks quite liquid but by the time it
bakes has this really nice rich crust on
top and then
just a nice little nutmeg
on top
now bake at 180 for 30 to 35 minutes
then take the porridge out sprinkle on
Demerara sugar and Grill to create a
sweet Golden Crust
and sort of glaze on top
beautiful literally for three to four
minutes
look at that
that makes me feel proud to be Scottish
because it's perfect for a big Comfort
family breakfast it's Rich it's
Sumptuous and it's just a humble oatmeal
phenomenal especially in the winter my
spiced baked porridge with all those
nuts and fruit it's a bowl full of love
to start the day
[Music]
next I'm showing you how to cook the
comfort food I crave
but first here's a closer look at some
of the key ingredients you'll need to
make them
[Music]
My ultimate comfort food has to be
sausage I grew up on the classic British
Banger made with ground pork salt pepper
spices and breadcrumbs and I'm using
these ones for dinner
the general rule with sausage the higher
the meat content the better they'll
taste
[Music]
for my ultimate lunch I'm frying fish so
you'll need an oil you can get to a high
temperature here are the different oils
you can use
groundnut oil it's made from peanuts and
it's used a lot in Southeast Asian
cooking grape seeds made from those
yellow flowering crops this has the
lowest saturated fat content of any oil
and has a lovely delicate flavor
sunflower oil made from sunflower seeds
is mildly nutty
cheap all-rounder with a neutral flavor
is vegetable oil which is the blend of
oils like corn soybean and sunflower
[Music]
apples were my favorite fruit growing up
originally came from China but today in
Britain we grow over 2 000 different
types
[Music]
the most popular eating apples in the UK
are Braven and Gala but don't miss out
on some of the older types like the
sweet nutty russets and fragrant coxes
when it comes to cooking apples it's got
to be a sharp Bramley which I'm using as
part of my compot for lunch
you know that feeling when you really
want a particular dish and nothing else
will do that's comfort food multimet
comforting lunch has to be fished with
peas I've loved it ever since I was a
kid and to make it even more delicious
I've given it a few modern tweaks
for my Ultimate Fish I'm doing the best
crunchiest lightest batter imaginable
with a hint of Ginger to go with it
chili minted mushy peas
[Music]
in order to make sure that the batter
stays nice and crispy and the fish stays
nice and firm
the secret is to season the fish salt
and pepper that will draw out the
moisture and that'll keep the fish
really nice and firm
put it in the fridge for around 10
minutes to let the seasoning work its
magic that the batter as always
when making any batter always sieve the
flour I want a bit of heat in the batter
so a nice teaspoon of cayenne pepper
season the flour salt and pepper
and then two teaspoons of baking powder
this almost lightens the lobe of the
batter now ginger beer it gives that
batter the sort of unique spicy
individual flavor it's delicious for the
fish and a nice tablespoon of oil
just basic vegetable oil gives it a nice
Sheen give that a good mix
you really want it almost like the
consistency of double cream
too thin and the Basset runs off
especially when it hits the fryer too
thick and it actually prevents the fish
from getting cooked so you've got to get
it to that just that sort of double
cream texture let it rest for as long as
possible to give you an even textured
batter now the season should have worked
its magic and drawn out the excess
moisture from the fish so it's on to the
next stage fish
I was going slightly firm
perfect for frying start by coating the
fish in flour seasoned with pepper hats
that nice and dry into your hands so you
haven't got any excess flour the flour
stops the batter from running off the
fish I'm just gonna check to see if my
oil's ready by putting a little touch of
batter into the fryer you see it
bubbling straight to the very top
that tells you that the oil is ready
never really ever
fill the pan above halfway if the oil
starts to get too hot
first thing you do turn off the gas
second thing add some oil into it to
cool it down
hold the fish by the corner
unless you put it in
and roll it round
then gently slap the fish on the sides
of the bowl to get rid of excess batter
now
in
and lay away
and just gently drop it in
twist your pan
that stops IT from sticking at the
bottom oil should be gently sort of
bubbling away
but notice as we're frying the fish
there's no spitting of any water from
the fish fry the fish for three to five
minutes gently turning halfway through
once the batter's golden and crisp it's
ready look they look stunning it's like
these big crispy pillows of beautifully
textured Cod leave the fish to rest on
the kitchen towel to blot excess oil
meanwhile it's quick and easy chili
minted mushy peas
now how much your peas a little teaspoon
of olive oil
nice
knob of butter into the pan
shallot finely chopped that adds a bit
of sweetness to the peas shots into the
pan
chili
these are delicious when you eat peas
and they're slightly spicy they're even
better
garlic
in the peas sweat off the chili the
garlic and the slots
before the peas join those spices simply
blanch in salted boiling water infused
with their perfect partner fresh mint
stalks on all
and then put your frozen peas in now
what's the piece I've got nice and soft
drain them now take off the stalks and
then add your peas to the shallots
I love that sound
mix all that chili and garlic
in there a little seasoning
finishing the frozen peas off like this
absolutely delicious
onto your board
Crush
now
you cannot beat
crushed delicious peas
those peas is incredible
chopped mint
chili minted mushy peas so simple and
perfect with easy ginger beer battered
fish
a nice spicy crispy batter and that just
reaffirms the importance of comfort food
if you're going to do it
do it properly
[Music]
my spicy twist is proof you can update a
comforting classic and the best way to
eat this is with Crispy buttered saute
potatoes cooked with garlic Rosemary and
Thyme
to take this happy food to a whole new
level
[Music]
no question about it the best comfort
food is definitely homemade wonderful
smells from in the kitchen delicious
freshly cooked food and a big side order
of nostalgia for me fantastic stews hot
pots and puddings will always hit the
mark and remind me of my mum that's why
I love them my ultimate comforting
dinner is a real favorite in our house
and I hope it will always remind my kids
of me
[Music]
and joining me in the kitchen to cook
the comfort food of my childhood as my
youngest daughter Tilly
[Music]
food dinner is a stunning sausage Hot
Pot which will serve with a gorgeous
potato and beetroot gratin
now I love Hot Pot you love Hot Pot
and you love sausages right yeah what'd
you enjoy most about sausages
just love having them
these are
little button mushrooms okay you just
take them into there like that
we keep the hole and cut them into
quarters please now the important thing
about cooking sausages is they need a
bit of color right no color no flavor
exactly get the pan nice and hot how was
school today
school was good thanks we got to go out
and mix now
sausages in
okay buttered mushrooms in there please
my darling see
now
I'm going to watch your fingers but you
know how to slice onions right
definitely
now sausages
I get in lots of color because this is
going to cook slowly
and it's sort of Daddy's version of
the kind of hot pot the other one
nannies to make for me yeah yeah once
you've got the color on them
and check them out
to rest okay
a little knob of butter okay into the
pan
now it looks like a lot of onions right
yeah as they start sweating down they
caramelize
so that'll go down by half give that a
little fry okay salt in
I want you to put a nice tablespoon of
brown sugar in there that gets them
really nice and dark now get your thyme
in
pick off all the little buds
that will get the onions
pack the flavor
smells nice washrooms in give them a
nice little stir did you like to help
Nan make your hot pot when she made them
for you I used to always help now make
the hot pot
always now my mum would never have used
this but A's balsamic vinegar brings out
the flavor of the onions right now look
at her onions look beautiful caramelized
the vinegar has given that nice sort of
gloss I'm gonna put my sausages back in
here now from there
some red wine
red wine in
got the flavor underneath there
going into the sausages now the sausage
is going to release all that flavor
inside as well look at the color of that
and it's still not cooked yet up to the
ball really important to boil it here
because it won't boil in the oven 170 in
the oven literally
18 to 20 minutes and she goes nice
to go with my hot pot Rich golden creamy
potato gratin it's a true comfort food
classic and I'm adding a delicious twist
beetroot
start by gently heating double cream
[Music]
then peel and thinly sliced potatoes and
cook beetroot
foreign
next rub garlic around the edge of your
dish to thoroughly season with a
glorious flavor then grease with a good
layer of butter
arrange alternate layers of potato
and beetroot
seasoning in between
[Music]
end with a neat layer of potatoes and
pour the hot cream over the top
bake in a preheated oven for an hour or
until the potatoes are tender
[Music]
potato and beetroot gratin are bubbling
beauty of a comfort food dish
now for the Apple compod what we need to
do first is to get these peeled and
sliced
I got my pan on to get nice and hot now
let me give you a little taste of that
thanks for the warning
blew my head off they're incredibly
acidic okay and you need to cook them
those wonderful red apples you've got
are called Brae Burns what other apples
you know cream ones what are they called
um
the green ones another word for your nan
Grandma's no
red no Pink Lady apple no Granny Smith
Granny Smith apples that's right what
we're gonna do is cook the cooking
apples and
the eating apples together I love the
combination of the tartness from the
Bramley cooking apple with the sweetness
of the Brae bun get the pan nice and hot
sprinkle the bottom of the pan
with caster sugar
three or four nice slices of fresh
ginger and three little cinnamon sticks
I want you to remember that because
we're going to look for them okay
because once we use them and they've
worked their magic I need to pull them
out see all the sugar dissolving
now we just let that go a little bit
darker
okay and then
the place is quick doesn't it
give that a nice
little toss
okay a nice golden color cinnamon in
ginger in so
we're cooking down the apples
butter in
gently cook until the apples soften then
take off the heat
let me go into there what's that coming
out Dan so that is a little bit of the
puree I'll show you we'll do that in a
minute how many Ginger
four four Ginger
three cinnamon three cinnamon out with a
cinnamon
and take
a
spoon
of apples
it smells so nice how nice is that look
see the color of apples let's put these
in the fridge to get nice and cold
that's the Comfort sorted easy now a
simple creamy whip to Crown the top you
separate the egg whites into there for
Daddy
right egg whites are in I think it's
separate off of your day
[Music]
and I'll sprinkle the sugar in and then
you turn up the speed
should go
[Music]
there's obviously now let's see if
you've got a really nice stiff Pig so
you lift them up
and that is what I call a nice stiff
peak well done not bad not bad next in a
separate Bowl whip double cream until
stiff
nice and slowly
foreign
whips so much quicker
we're gonna put some delicious lemon
zest
which will make the cream
so much better then sweeten it up with
leftover caramely compote puree
and you mix that in nice and carefully
it says like this apple butterscotch now
to make the cream even lighter fold in
those whisked egg whites and sugar egg
whites
into the cream
just nicely fold that in
so we bring your glasses back out
manage the glasses yep good girl
hmm silly we're on for a treat open up
the Piping Bag now to the end
now you could spoon this in but I want
to just give a nice little lift it also
gives it a nice pattern lemon on top
the fridge the beetroot and potato
gratin is that lovely that's lovely
sausages
finished with a flat leaf parsley
look at those two beauties it doesn't
get any more comforting than that does
it for one of the best hot pots
ever Tilly that looks amazing
well done
this is my ultimate comfort food dinner
sausage hot pot with potato and beetroot
gratin followed by Apple comp art
food with guaranteed feel-good Factor
mommy Jack Holly Megan
doesn't it
smells amazing
tasty delicious one of my favorites so
tasty I love it this is so good I love
the mushrooms as well that is so nice
and so simple when I was your age guys
Nanny was making this for me in those
days the sausages weren't as fast you
would ride to school on dinosaurs
excuse me I'm not out
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
foreign